growing up in the spotlight is never
easy but keeping the spotlight seemed to
be even harder for Miranda Cosgrove
whatever happened to one of the world's
biggest child stars you may know her as
the iconic Carly from Nickelodeon's
iCarly or Jack Black's protege in the
blockbuster hit School of Rock but the
27 year old actress slowly faded out of
Hollywood after her hugely successful
trials of career ended back in 2012 so
why exactly did Hollywood stop casting
Miranda Cosgrove shockingly a break from
the spotlight was her plan from the
start and her comeback into the world of
acting is only just beginning I think
anyone can be an inspiration in their
own way Miranda never set out to be
discovered instead the world of red
carpets and flashing lights found her
the actress was signed to an agent at
just three years old after being spotted
singing and dancing during a casual
family dinner
in fact her parents saw it as a way to
help her future outside of the
entertainment biz Miranda even admitted
to USA Today that when she first started
acting her parents literally thought
she'd get a few commercials and they put
it in a college fund however fate had
other plans and it turned out that their
daughters potential was just too big to
contain in the blink of an eye the LA
native was breaking Guinness records for
being the second highest-paid child
actor only behind two and a half men's
Angus Jones landed her first Hollywood
role in 2003 with Jack Black in School
of Rock the film's huge box-office
success
basically catapulted her into the world
of Nickelodeon where she grew up
alongside fan favorite stars like Josh
Peck Drake Bell and Jamie Lynn Spears
she first impressed the television
industry with her role as a devious
little sister Megan Parker on Drake and
Josh the networks loved her work so much
she sprinkled her talent on TVs around
the world as many different characters
her quick wit and hilarious acting
landed her appearances on plenty of hit
series like grounded for life what's new
scooby-doo and lilo and Stitch she even
lived out every teens dream of being an
elite PC a student on zoey 101
although fans of Drake and Josh were
forced to bid a sad farewell to Megan
Parker when the show wrapped in 2007
Nickelodeon wasn't quite ready to let
Miranda escape their grips going from a
prankster younger sister to an Internet
sweetheart her career took off when she
scored her own show that
of you may have heard of iCarly she's
Carly Carly Sam Miranda alongside
jennette mccurdy and nathan kress
brought the quirky and spirited carly
shay and her best friends Sam Puckett
and Freddie Benson to life being one of
the first shows to delve into the world
of online entertainment in social media
iCarly was an instant hit for the
network and Miranda soon became a
household name across North America
winning and presenting awards at the
Nickelodeon Kids Choice Awards quickly
became a yearly tradition for the cast
and soon Miranda was scouted by another
major production company the one the
only Disney while in the midst of
filming iCarly
Miranda was offered the opportunity to
voice Despicable meas Margo and much
like School of Rock the animated film
was a huge success
it was so successful among the younger
demographic that she went on to voice
the spunky character for two more
sequels credit after credits seemed to
stack on Miranda's resume the things
mysteriously began to slow down as she
got older while she strived to move away
from her younger audience and take on
more mature roles her movies like the
intruders were met with staggering low
ratings and she just couldn't shake her
Nickelodeon sweetheart image luckily for
her she found music as a way to reach
audiences outside of her young fans in
between filming for iCarly the star
released multiple hit songs her album
sparks fly even debuted at number eight
on the Billboard charts but in 2011 when
she embarked on her first ever tour
tragedy struck her tour bus was involved
in accidents and left her with a broken
ankle and a list of canceled concert
dates
although fans expected her to reschedule
there was never any news on a make up
tour and the a-lister quietly left the
music scene returning to icarly for one
more season the show wrapped in 2012 and
the actress's career literally came to a
halt while it left fans of the actress
wondering why exactly she was being
rejected from Hollywood
Miranda admits leaving a spotlight was
always part of her plan her parents
dream of Miranda one day attending
college was never forgotten
in fact the actress carried the same
mindset into her adult
being able to go to college was my goal
is what she confessed during an
interview with USA Today that's right
the actress wind from challenging
Authority to securing a spot in one of
America's most prestigious universities
fresh off of set this actress took on
the world of textbooks and tests at the
University of Southern California where
she set out to do what we all do at
least once in our lives find herself
because she was pushed into Hollywood at
such a young age
Miranda truly wanted to discover whether
acting was the right career path for her
it was really important to me to go to
college and just see what other
opportunities were out there don't panic
after four years and no doubt a ton of
essays Miranda completed a degree in
psychology but has realized that acting
will always be her passion it's what I
really love and want to do according to
the su journal the child star also went
to college with the intention of trying
to build a name for herself outside of
icarly
one where the industry and her fans
wouldn't always associate Nickelodeon
with the actress in some way I wonder if
I'd never done anything
would I be seen in a different way I
played Carly for so long it's hard for
some people to think of me as someone
else a world well miranda cosgrove isn't
carly shay and that even exists no one
knows for sure but since her graduation
miranda has been putting a huge effort
into landing some edgier and more mature
roles and so far things have gone
smoothly
it looks like the actress might be well
on her way to being welcomed back into
mainstream media and if her upcoming
projects are any indication we should
all be excited if you thought Miranda
working with Jack Black was absolute
peak energy
wait until you see photos of the iCarly
star with her new BFF the queen of
acting herself Betty White
following her time in school Miranda
landed her first major television role
since icarly on the comedy series
crowded where she played shame or a
young adult who was looking to move back
in with her parents
although the comedy only lasted one
season Miranda seems to have formed a
tight bond with Betty when she
guest-starred on the series I guess we
could call her the fifth golden girl not
only did Betty post about her new
friendship herself thrilled to be
working with old friends and new on at
NBC crowded but Miranda also posted a
birthday tribute to the Golden Girls
star calling her one of the sweetest
most talented people she's ever met
working in comedy made for an older
audience and making some iconic
connections is just the tip of the
iceberg when it comes to Miranda's adult
career oh no we didn't practice we did
the exact thing everyone accuses our
generation of in 2019 she made her
return to the big screen with the very
adult thriller
30:22 not only was it a completely new
vibe for the audience but an entirely
different experience for Miranda things
have continued to pick up for the star
with a schedule of projects set to be
released right into summer 2020 the
actress will be reuniting with Pharrell
Williams for his newest film North
Hollywood that will focus on pro skaters
and is even to set to make an appearance
on Hollywood game night alongside Ellen
DeGeneres's DJ twitch Amber Riley and
the iconic Bill Nye the Science Guy she
spent the last few months dabbling in
the world of producing and hosting with
her newest CBS serious mission
unstoppable looks like her college
degree may be coming in handy for her
newest adventure the series is meant to
give young girls a look at some of the
most empowering women in careers of
science math and technology around the
world and according to E W she's loving
being able to reconnect with her fans in
such a different way it's been really
fun just like getting to be part of
something like this and it's totally new
for me as for her career Miranda admits
that her dreams of becoming a pop star
have been put to rest for now
sometimes I'll play my guitar and I'll
sing songs and put them on Instagram but
that's really all I'm doing right now
for the most part it's just something
that I do on the side sometimes while
things have definitely changed since her
last time being a torturous younger
sister or up-and-coming web star Miranda
has made it clear that the amazing
connection she's made over the years are
just as strong as they were decades ago
this elaborate United with her school of
rock classmates back in 2016 for the
Broadway premiere where they looked
closer than ever
speaking the bustle Miranda says I'm
friends with all of them and describes
that their unique relationships have
left her with strong connections across
the whole country when I visit other
states there's pretty much one kid from
the movie in every state so wherever I
go visit somewhere I have a built-in
friend to meet up with Miranda's time on
Nickelodeon was also impactful in more
ways than just Fame the cast of both
Drake and Josh and iCarly have become
almost like family to the star jennette
mccurdy to this day is still the
actresses best friend from Disney World
dates to loving birthday messages their
tight bond has been plastered all across
social media over the
years she's the friend that everyone
deserves her on-screen brothers have
also capped a special place in her heart
in recent birthday messages to Jerry
Trainor the actors complimented her
former classmates for being the absolute
perfect team meant and thanks to
internet sensations david dobrik fans
got the reunion they deserved between
miranda and josh pat known for his
hilarious antics and outrageous pranks
david orchestrated a huge surprise for
josh that involves seeing Miranda for
the first time in so many years
he looks good boob in good old-fashioned
fun Miranda ends the reunion with a
classic pie in the face joke to prove
just how the two still care for each
other
they gave their fans the mostest algid
trip back to childhood where they
reacted to their past selves Miranda
loves to post throwback photos she finds
from her time on set while wanting to
make a name for herself outside of her
childhood is definitely understandable I
mean who would want to be remembered as
their preteen self forever Miranda
definitely recognizes how important her
earlier years were for her career in
fact she's not even opposed to a future
reboot she says she recognizes how her
fans feel about the series because of
her excitement over the revamp Lizzie
McGuire and admits she wants to keep
doing comedy and maybe someday icarly
would be fun to revisit it looks like
miranda cosgrove former co-stars haven't
stopped supporting the actress she might
have taken some time off to find herself
but doesn't that mean she's just like
you and I plus you have to admit her
glow up was epic are you looking forward
to this former Nickelodeon stars
upcoming projects would you watch an
icarly reboot let us know what you think
in the comment section below don't
forget to stay connected to the things
by hitting that subscribe button and
turning on your notifications until next
time